E4 G6 D4 and Knight F6 yeah this one has
several names like the Norwegian rat or
the North Sea defense yeah I think
one before I think professional name is
maybe this is a cold ski uh also known
as the orangutan yeah I think a lot of
the views might recognize as well from
the Champions chess tour
this position does it have another name
than the double vote wrong card or I
don't think so
so this one might be tricky D5
and Knight C3 I mean I have no idea it's
like kind of grumpy attack but not a
real grumpy attack it's called the
toilet variation because apparently Mark
came up with it while he was
in the toilet oh he also mentioned if
you Checkmate using the toilet variation
then that's a royal flush yeah